The next excerpts are taken from original tape W
one seventy six side
B.
me personally
my mammo new
variant is one of the ridges
the are black or white. I went
to the Falls turn off our
chart Springfield Missouri.
I don't know and learn that I was from the.
My brother allowed out the birds there are the
understandable. Hours there were
always the girl.
I would curse but I'm
not
before I get that there was a welfare every three hours a
week for three years.
How do you call them both the.
Two and three every week for three
years. But for those
who wait and first in the
Rolls. There's a week. Yanis the
girls turn.
Them cold and the good news there they were smart but what happened to me and I hope they wouldn't
happen again.
Or did the.
Lies and bullshit.
Were the words of.
Now a lawyer there are a couple that.
Love lives and we'll be back.
But it's no use.
No help.
This is my boyfriend. Please.
Girls and.
You need an adult.
Yes we want to be a law it.
And I know you gave them but I will
leave.
What happened to me oh why would they be as they appear to
do law school. First Lieutenant There
are fields
that he calls.
Two years and they were the lawyers the three.
The little the full day
the Noles the reunion with the commander there or.
Had a good life. No adult what has happened to me would
have brought out the last
letter. Remember it in about anywhere that.
Laurie make yourself or
something in your suffer like a mole whatever
one God knows you can take it you do.
He will bring you back. Naif Well it will become I'm
alone still no burning really.
The
you are you know
very well you know
very well
you know. The.
Ember curtain over there was all through it all
this
new that you are aware of their work and then the things in
the
world.